Çeviri: Elvan Ergün
Gözden geçirme: Erman Turkmen
Hoş geldiniz.
Şimdi ben çok uzun yıllardır
çok sayıda evliliğe eşlik etmiş,
iyi günlerini, kötü günlerini görmüş,
evlenmiş, boşanmış, sonrasında
danışanları tarafından "Acaba terzi
söküğünü dikemiyor mu?" denmiş,
yahut "Hocam tanıdığımız iyi bir terapist
var, isterseniz telefonunu verelim."
denmiş, iyi günleri ve kötü günleri olmuş,
iki çocuğu, anası babası, kardeşleri,
sahici dostları ve sevdiği adamı
olan bir kadınım.
Hayatından memnun bir kadınım.
(Alkış)
Bizim mevzu ilişki ve evlilik.
Fakat burada benim dilimin
durmaksızın kadın ve erkek
yahut evliliğe kaymasını dikkate almayın.
Siz lütfen ilişki zemininden
olayı okuyun, bir.
İki, katiyen homofobik okumayın.
LGBT'ye bir selam göndereyim
mutlak bir biçimde.
(Alkış)
Şöyle tarihsel bir bakarsak,
benim jenerasyonum ve aslında
benden biraz önceki jenerasyonun evliliği
ve ilişkiyi öğrenişi Türk filmlerinde.
Mevzu şuydu: Açık sinemalara
gidilir, çekirdek çitlenir,
bir esas kız ve esas oğlan vardır,
bunlar daima sosyoekonomik olarak
birbirinden farklıdır ve kavuşamazlar.
Eğer bir yol olur kavuşabilirlerse
o dakikada film biter.
Mesaj şudur, evlenildi ve
artık bütün problemler halloldu.
Biz kendi gençliğimiz boyunca,
onlar evlendikten sonra ne olduğunu
bir türlü göremedik.
Daha sonra boşanmalar arttı.
Haz çağı güncellendi ve bu defa biz
dizileri seyretmeye başladık.
Dizilerde ağır abiler var,
böyle uzaklara doğru bakıyorlar.
Elli kelimeyle konuşuyorlar.
Derin olduklarına dair
bir alt mesaj var ki
aslında sahiden
elli kelimeyle konuşuyorlar.
Heyecanlı, hafif hoppaca da onların
eşleri, sevgilileri formatında
genç bir kadın var ve bu ağır abilerin
vazifesi o genç hanımı hizaya sokmak.
Bu hikâyeden sonra da
narsist erkekseverlik şeklinde
toplum mühendisliğinin bir hediyesiyle
karşı karşıya kaldık
ki bu iyi bir şey diye düşünmüyorum.
Ben size biriktirdiklerimi anlatacağım.
Çokça evlilik tanıyorum, birkaç bin.
Hepsi parmak izi gibi.
Anlatacaklarımın hiçbiri size
uymayabilir, hepsi oturabilir.
Size uyanı alıp, uymayanı
bırakmanızı rica ediyorum.
Bir minik anektoddan sonra başlayacağım.
Evliliğin ya da ilişkinin, olabildiğince
ilişkiye çevirmeye çalışacağım,
yedi büyük günahı diye
bir hikâye anlatacağım.
Ben sayıları sevmiyorum.
Hani evliliğin 55 doğru yolu,
çocuk yetiştirmenin 25 şahane yöntemi.
Burada biriktirdiklerimi
ancak yediye sığdırabildim.
Geçen gün çocuklarım bana dediler ki
"Anne ne ruhsuzsun."
Burada oturmaktalar.
Hayırdır inşallah dedim.
"Aşk zaten biter deyip duruyorsun
her yerde, ne yapacağız?"
Düşündüm, hakikaten on altı yaşındakiler
için yahut kırkında, ellisindekiler
için bile ne fena bir bilgi
aşk zaten biter.
Korkuya mahal yok evladım dedim,
yaşanırken fark edilmiyor.
Senin yaşadığının tamamen farklı
bir şey olduğunu düşünüyorsun.
Zaten düşünmüyorsan da âşık değilsindir,
şuurun fazla yerinde demektir.
Şimdi evliliğin yedi büyük günahı derken,
ilişkinin yedi büyük günahı derken
şundan bahsediyorum aslında.
İlişkiler böyle uzunlamasına giderken
bir sürü yerde tökezliyorlar.
Daha yaygın tökezlediğimiz hâllerden,
daha keskin virajlardan bahsediyorum.
Birincisi, Allah rahmet eylesin,
bir anatomi profesörüdür Sami Zan,
koca bir amfide ders verir,
ufacık da bir adamdır ve
derslere sıklıkla da
şöyle başlar sene başında.
Der ki "Kızlarım lafım size,
koca terbiye edilmez, terbiyelisi alınır."
Burada, bu elbet erkeklere de söylenebilir
bir hikâyedir ama kadınların cebinde
partnerleriyle ilgili iddialı bir
değiştirilecekler listesi vardır.
Yaptım biliyorum.
Çokça yapanı da tanıyorum aynı zamanda.
Denir ki, değiştirme listenizin olduğu
hiç kimseyle evlenmeyin,
uzunlamasına ilişkiye girmeyin.
Yeni jenerasyonun tarifiyle
takılabilirsiniz, o ayrı mevzu.
Peki, değişmeyecek miyiz yani?
Adamı aldık, öyle dondu kaldı,
bitti mi hikâye?
Değil, herkes değişiyor, mutlak değişiyor,
önünde durulabilir bir şey değil değişim.
Fakat eğer sizin bir listeniz olursa,
o insanın kendi olağan seyrinin
önüne geçiyorsunuz,
bir proje hâline getiriyorsunuz.
Çünkü benlik ve bünye doğal olarak
direnç koyuyor ve kendini koruyor.
Burada bir ikinci tarif var,
buna hastayım.
Jung diyor ki bir kadın ve adamın ilişkisi
kimyasal bir tepkimeye benzer.
Eğer tepkime gerçekleşirse
her ikisi de kılık değiştirir.
Bu, şu demek: gönül gönle değerse
zaten o değişim kendi seyri
ve süreci içinde olur, bu bir.
İkinci madde, köken aileler en çok
tökezlediğimiz yerlerden biri
ilişkilerde ve evliliklerde.
Biz memlekete ait çok alt dinamiklere
sahip bir coğrafyayız.
Eğer biz bugün bu toplantıyı
Oslo'da yapıyor olsaydık
köken aileden hiç bahsetmiyor olacaktık.
Onlar zaten çocukları 18'inde
postalamış olacaklardı
ve daha bireysel insanlar olacaktık.
İyi kötü, ayrı hikâye.
Ama bu coğrafyada biz,
özerkleşmesi daha az,
köken ailelerle bağları daha fazla,
iddialı sosyal destekler alan
ve bununla ilgili de birtakım
bedeller ödeyen hâllerdeyiz.
Asıl köken aile derdinin
daha az afili söylenişi şudur:
Kayınvalide - gelin problemi.
Burada hikâye şudur,
ortada bir tane adamcağız vardır.
Hakikaten de adamcağızdır ama.
Bir tarafında ona yıllarını vermiş anne,
öbür tarafta geleceğini vaat eden kadın.
Burada yapılacak temel mesele, adam
ortadan pılı pırtıyı toplayacak, gidecek
-mutlak bir biçimde- ve o iki kadın
birbirleriyle ilişki kurmayı öğrenecekler.
Burada daima genç olanın performansının
daha iddialı ve başarılı olması beklenir.
Burası bataklık alandır,
çok olağanüstü dikkat etmeliyiz.
Herkesin kendi ailesiyle
kurduğu ilişkideki sınıra
parmağımızın ucunu sokmamayı öneririm.
Elbette ki gelişeceğiz, olgunlaşacağız,
bu ilişkiler de değişecek.
Sevmeye çalışmanın çok kıymetli olduğunu
düşünüyorum ben partnerin ailesini,
epey geçinmeye gönlü olmanın.
Mayanız tutmayabilir, tutmadıysa da
nezaketin çok yukarıda olması lazımdır.
Cinsellik günah değil,
cinselliğin ihmal edilmesi fena günah.
İlişkilerde ve evliliklerdeki en hızlı
irtifa kaybeden alanlardan biri cinsellik.
Bir kere memleketin
bu konudaki sakatı çok.
Evlenilecek ve eğlenilecek
kadın: Terminolojiler.
Yere bakarak yürümenin
edepli olduğu bir coğrafya.
Erkeklerin cinselliği algılayışındaki
o performans kaygısı,
yanı sıra da bunu bir performans
sanatı gibi algılayışları.
Tabii uzunlamasına giden,
evlilik formatındaki ilişkilerde,
eskilerin fingirdemek dediği, bizim flört
etmek dediğimiz hikâye çok kıymetli.
Cinselliğin aslında
ilk üçteki sarsılmaz yeri,
bir kadın ve adamın ilişkisinde
olağanüstü derecede kıymetli.
Zaten bir arada oluşları, bir kadın ve
adam olmakla ilgilidir ve
cinsellik de bunun altını çok bold
çizen hâllerden biridir.
Kadının o saygın ve saygıdeğer
olmakla ilgili coğrafyadan gelen ve
aslında onu epey sakatlamış olan
hikâyesinden kurtulması bir vakit alır.
Yıllar önce yanılmıyorsam 2. ya da
3. deneyimim çift görmeye başladığımda,
ellili yaşlara yakın
bir beyefendi ve eşi var.
Hanımefendi boşanmak istiyor,
beyefendi diyor ki hayatta boşanmam.
Niye dedik.
"Memlekette kadın kadın olur
yaşı kırkı bulur." dedi.
Ben bunu yıllar içerisinde,
20 yıl öncesinden bahsediyorum,
mükerrer kere düşündüm.
Aslında o kendinizi serbest
bırakışınızla ilgili uzun bir vakit geçer.
Yeni jenerasyonun bu konuda daha hoyrat
olduğunu düşünüyorum, cinsellik konusunda.
Daha nesnel olduğunu düşünüyorum,
ama kendi bedenleri konusunda
daha sağlıklı olduğunu
düşünüyorum aynı zamanda.
Dört.
Şimdi ilişkilerin sıkı tökezlediği
yerlerden biri aslında dünyada da,
bizim coğrafyada da en sert
tökezlediği yer ebeveyn olunan vakit.
Anne baba olmakla karı koca
ya da kadın erkek olmak
birbirinden epey ayrı hâller.
Hiç benzemiyorlar neredeyse.
Ebeveynlik çok kutsal
atıfları olan bir hikâye.
Dolayısıyla ilişkinin üstünü sarıyor.
Bir vakit sonra siz kendinizi
salt ebeveyn gibi görmeye başlıyorsunuz.
Eski jenerasyonlar bunu bilir,
buna da fittir, dert yok.
Yeni jenerasyon, mutlu olmak ve haz almak
konusunda iddialı ve iddiacı.
Buralarda o kaybedilen haz,
ilişkinin en sert tökezlemelerinden
biri hâline geliyor.
Yurtdışında bazı terapi merkezleri,
doğum sonrası üç dört yıl içinde
gördüğü vakit çifti, yalnız zaman
geçirme kontratı olmadan görmüyor.
Amerikalılar en çok doğumdan sonraki
ilk dört yıl içinde boşanıyorlar,
çünkü o denge sarsılıyor.
Katiyen ve katiyen bu hatların birbiriyle
hiçbir bağlantısı neredeyse olmadığını
iyi görmemiz gerek.
Burada iki şey önemli.
Bir, çocuksuz zaman geçireceğiz.
Çok kıymetli.
İki, birbirimizin ebeveynliğine
müdahale etmeyeceğiz.
Herkesin bahtına
bir anneyle baba düşüyor.
Burada oturan iki evladımın
bahtına ben düşmüş durumdayım.
Günün sonunda iyisi, kötüsü,
doğrusu, eğrisi baş edecekler.
Eğer özel bir maraz yoksa,
birbirimizin ebeveynliğinden
pılı pırtıyı toplayıp çıkaracağız.
Herkes kendi usulünce ebeveynlik yapacak.
Hani o magazinel bir biçimde
çocuğa aynı şeyi söylememiz gerekiyor
efsanesinden kurtulacağız.
Elbette ortaklık yapmamız gereken alanlar
var ama tamamen ayrı hatlarda gidiyoruz.
Ben epey bu anlamda
dert yaşamış insan tanırım.
Geldik beş.
En büyük günah, açık ara
en büyük günah içgörü.
En basit karşılığı aslında
kendini bilmek demek.
İçgörü mevzusu, bu hayat dediğiniz hikâye
kendinden insan yaratma macerasıdır ya,
bu macerada aslında cebimizdeki
en kıymetli malzeme.
Kendimiz için, ilişkimiz için,
çoluğumuz çocuğumuz için,
aslında her şey için çok kıymetli.
Hikâyenin dibinde
ve temelinde oturan mevzu.
İlişkideki içgörüde birkaç tane
sorunun çok iyi cevaplanması lazım.
İlişki içgörüsünün en temel sorusu
"ben nerede yanlış yapıyorum"dur.
Fakat bu sorunun cevabı,
"çok iyi niyetliyim,
o yüzden hata yapıyorum"
samimiyetsizliğinde bir cevap değil.
Burada üç soru var.
1. Niye evleniyorum bu adamla, öbürüyle
değil de bu adamla ya da bu kadınla?
2. Nerede dert yaşıyorum?
3. Bu yaşadıklarımda benim rolüm nedir?
Şimdi bu niye evlendiğimiz ya da
aşk hissettiğimiz o şahsiyeti
sevdiğimiz sorusunun cevabı karmaşıktır.
İhtiyaçlarımız tercihlerimizi belirliyor.
İhtiyaçlarımız değişebiliyor, bu defa
tercihimiz aynı şekilde değişmeyebiliyor.
Misal, adamla çok canlı diye evleniyoruz,
eve hiç girmiyor diye boşanıyoruz.
Yahut, kadınla beni çok derliyor
topluyor, hayatıma müthiş bir düzen
getirdi diye evleniyoruz
ve anne-kadın istemiyorum,
daha canlı birini istiyorum
diye boşanıyoruz.
Şimdi hikâyenin burasında
ihtiyaçlar değişiyor.
Dolayısıyla eğer o değişen ihtiyaçlarla
beraber partner ve ilişki de
benzer bir ahenkte değişirse ne âlâ,
yoksa işimizde iddialı zorluklar var.
Bir ilişkide yaşanan dertlerin sayısını
çıkarmak olası değil.
Buradan, bugün konuşmaya başlayıp
bir ay sonra bitirsek yetmez.
İletişim kuramıyoruz,
beni seviyor, beni sevmiyor,
ailesiyle ilgili derdim var, duygusunu
çok aktarıyor, hiç aktarmıyor,
benimle çok ilgileniyor, hiç ilgilenmiyor,
çok arka bahçesi var, arka bahçesi yok.
Kocaman!
Çok kişisel burada, parmak izi gibi
her çiftin tarifi farklı.
Şu üçüncü sorunun cevabı
benim için çok kıymetli.
Ben nerede hata yaptım ilişkide,
ne yapıyorum, yanlışım ne?
Şimdi bu soru çiftlerle görüşürken
dananın kuyruğunun koptuğu yerdir.
Nedir sizin katkınız dersiniz
bu olup biten hikâyeye.
Der ki çok sinirlendiriyor beni,
çok küsüyor, çok iletişimsiz.
Peki, siz ne yapıyorsunuz dersiniz.
"Yapıyorum ama" diye
başlayan cümleler olur.
Ama ile başlayan her gerekçe patinajdır,
gerisi de hikâyedir.
Yani adam bağırıyordur, kadın küsüyordur.
Bağırdığı için küsüyorum,
küstüğü için bağırıyorum.
Bu dehlizden çıkılmaz.
Hikâye ancak şöyledir.
"Yanlış yapıyorum, bağırıyorum."
ayrı bir hikâyedir.
"Yanlış yapıyorum, küsüyorum."
İlişki içgörüsünde herkes kendiyle ilgili
yüksek samimiyet ile
kendine dair olanı bulmakla mükelleftir.
Hayat için de mükellefiz bunda.
Yani doğrumuz var, eğrimiz var,
ucuz yanımız var, zayıf yanımız var.
Geldik altı, iletişim.
Ben hayatını dinleyerek ve
konuşarak kazanan biriyim.
Konuşmayı da seven biriyim üstelik.
Buna rağmen son zamanlarda
duyduğum zaman beni rahatsız eden
kelimelerden biri hâline geldi iletişim.
İletişimin tabii üstadları var.
Kelimelere takla attıranlar var,
şahane yapanlar var.
Fakat iletişimde
çok kıymetli bir dip not var,
onun pas geçilmesi
hikâyeyi çok zorlaştırıyor.
İletişim şu; ben size anlatıyorum,
siz beni anlıyorsunuz, şahane.
Siz anlatıyorsunuz,
ben de anlıyorum, şahane.
Katiyen uzlaşmak durumunda değiliz.
Fakat kullandığımız kelimeler arttıkça
ve biz aslında iletişimi
bir performans sanatı gibi
yönetmeye başladıkça,
iletişim anlattığım anlaşılır ve
kabul edilir hikâyesine doğru
büyük bir hızla ilerlemekte.
Çiftler arasındaki iletişimde, şu tarifin
çok kıymetli olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Uzlaşamayacağınız alanlar olduğu
konusunda uzlaşmalısınız.
Bir kadın, bir adam, ayrı alt kültürler,
ayrı, ayrı, ayrı.
Her alanda uzlaşmaya kalktıkları zaman,
yani iletişimin sihir olduğunu,
iyi iletiştikleri zaman illa ki
uzlaşacakları gibi bir alt bilgiye
sahip oldukları vakit, bir adım sonrasında
restleşmeye başlıyorlar ve
o bizim en yaygın gördüğümüz bataklıktır.
Dolayısıyla iletişim kıymetli,
insan sözle, gözle, gönülle,
bir sürü şeyle iletişir,
doğru yanlış iletişir.
Velev ki uzlaşmama ihtimalini
cebinde tutmalıdır.
Ve yedi, benim en sevdiğim madde.
Ben evliliğin akıllı bir iş olduğunu
düşünmüyorum, gayet net.
Evliliği seviyorum ve onuyorum.
Çocuklarıma en az bir kere
evlenmelerini de öneririm ve herkese.
Sonrasını ve devamını bilmem
ama herkesin mutlak deneyimlemesi
gerektiğini düşünürüm evli olma hâlini.
Fakat akıllı bir hikâye olduğunu
külliyen düşünmüyorum.
Aynı hayat, aynı insanlar,
aynı yatak, aynı ev, aynı, aynı, aynı.
Bunun içinden beklediğimiz iddialı
bir haz var aynı zamanda.
Fakat bu hikâye bütün hayal kırıklıklarına
rağmen yıllardır devam ediyor.
Dolayısıyla başka bir şeye
hizmet ediyor olmalı.
Daha derinde bir hayali olmalı,
az ulaşılan bir hayali olmalı.
Pek az çiftin yakalayabildiği ama
daha derin bir hevesi olmalı evliliğin.
Evliliğin katiyen bir akıl oyunu değil,
istek oyunu olduğunu düşünmekteyim ben.
İnsanın dünya ile ilişkisinde
aktardıklarından daha başkasını,
daha derinini, daha zaafını,
daha yetersizliğini
kritize edilmeden, paralanmadan,
reddedilmeden isteyebileceği bir adres.
Gönül, gönül yarenini istiyor,
ahbabını istiyor,
kendini doğrusuyla eğrisiyle
kabul buyuracak olanını istiyor.
Evliliğin dolaşmak istediği yer burası.
Pek azımız dolaşıyoruz ve fakat
fantazisinin burası olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Şimdi, baştan sayalım günahları.
Bir: Değiştireceğimiz
kişiyle evlenmiyoruz.
İki: Biriyle evlenmek aynı zamanda onun
aile dinamiğiyle evlenmek demektir.
Maharetli ve dikkatli oluyoruz
aile ilişkilerinde.
Üç: Cinsellik daima ilk üçteki
sarsılmaz yerini koruyacak, çok kıymetli.
Dört: Evliliği ebeveynliğe satmıyoruz,
ikisi birbirinden ayrı hâller.
Beş: İçgörü çok mühim.
İnsan olmamızın yolculuğu içerisinde
olağanüstü derecede mühim ve
olmadan olmaz, olmadan en
olmayacak hâl olduğunu düşünürüm ben.
Kendimizi bilmeden
yola devam etme şansımız yok.
Altı: İletişeceğiz hiç itirazım yok
ve fakat uzlaşmama ihtimalini de
cebimizde bulunduracağız.
Yedi: Evlilik bir akıl
oyunu değil, istek oyunudur.
Efendim, yolunuzun, yönünüzün ve
gönlünüzün açık olmasını dilerim.
(Alkışlar)